I would actually see if I can test your
abilities with randomness if you can do
me something do me a favor so you know
flipping a coin heads or tails alright
so I want you to be coin flipper in your
mind and I want you to flip a coin in
your mind randomly 20 times and write
down the result here but don't show me
you've done 20 okay now I don't want to
see but what's gonna happen is I'm gonna
try and make money off your list so what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna give you a
bunch of pennies and you don't have to
pay me back they're yours and these are
mine
I bet to play and if I win you give me
that amount and if I lose you keep that
amount all right so I'm just going to
put a penny down there's one penny
riding on this okay so my first
prediction is that you flipped ahead yes
yes
so buddy says head so I'm gonna take one
of your coins from your stack okay I
gave them to you anyway so you shouldn't
be too miffed put another coin in okay
I'm gonna predict tails oh so you've
said head okay next I'm going to predict
tails not tails next I'm going to
predict tails and I'm going to bet $20
that I'm right what did you what was it
heads or tails
it was tails you owe me 20 bucks okay so
I'm just gonna put that aside all right
shall we keep playing I'm gonna bet
another coin just remember you're only
20 us I wanted in us if that's okay
okay I'm gonna bet another coin I'm
gonna predict tails yeah it is tails
okay tails it is alright so I get
another coin there
to predict heads I'm going to predict
tails tails it is so that was another
coin from you heads no okay so you get
to keep that tails no it's a head so you
get that heads heads it is alright so I
get another coin from you this is
turning out alright
you remember you've got the 20 to give
me okay I'm gonna predict tails yeah it
is a tail yeah so I get another coin
from you heads it is a head
okay I'm gonna predict a tail is it a
tail yeah tail okay I'm going to predict
ahead okay you get that coin I'm gonna
predict another head it was a head so I
get a coin from you tail was a tail and
I predict another tail know it's a head
so I'm going to predict a head right
last one 400 bucks tail yeah it is a
tail that was expensive you should have
listened to the way I said this you've
done something fantastic for me you have
been really bad at creating random
sequences as I can see here the longest
run that you've had is right at the
beginning it was three heads and then
you've pretty much alternated between
tails and heads tails and heads the most
run that you've had of tails or heads is
two in a row and you showed a pattern
there let's demonstrate something called
the gamblers fallacy the gamblers
fallacy is says that what's happened
before has an impact of what will happen
next if we were using a coin every time
you flip it there's an equal probability
that you've only get a head or a tail
now other people think well how does
that work because you know you're
flipping coins surely it's not very
likely to have
you know five heads in a row six heads
in a row but this is the nature of
randomness randomness is very lumpy
right and lumpiness means that you do
get streaks which is part of the
gamblers lexicon you know there's like
we have a gambling streak so you
actually have not produced a very good
random sequence he didn't put enough
streaks in nine this this is actually
would be termed homogeneous because it's
actually quite mixed the number of ways
that we can have twenty heads or tails
the number of permutations we can have
is pretty big so we can basically get a
head or a tail in each position and
there's 20 positions so the total number
of permutations not combinations like
fixed order is 2 to the power 20 and
that turns out to be 1,048,576 because
you've done a permutation which has a
maximum streak of either three heads or
three tails you only had one little tiny
streak right at the beginning which is
quite interesting that is a subset of
every single permutation but this is
actually representative of the way you
think and not just you brady a lot of
people think exactly like you if they
were to do random they think mixed up
right that's what people think but
random is it mixed up it random is
what's random in actual fact it has a
different nature to the idea of being
mixed up because if it was evenly mixed
up as I've just shown I've made a lot of
money off you you end up being
predictable and randomness is
unpredictable so I've actually crunched
the numbers and I can tell you how many
permutations have a maximum of three
heads or three tails as a streak 240
2830 so you can see that's a much
smaller number than this and an actual
fact it turns out to be 23.2%
of all possible permutations it's less
than 1/4 so out of all the possible
permutations you can have the pool that
you would choose from okay only is
you're only getting one in four so
can see just by that logic alone why
this well it's not random all right of
course I mean I wasn't consciously
limiting myself those strengths of three
I guess my brain was somehow well that's
a natural thing to do it because we
think streaks unlikely we tend to think
very small mindedly so if you were just
dealing with say four in a row having
four heads or four tails in a row is
actually in the minority because there's
only one way you can get four heads in a
row and only one way you can get four
tails in a row but we did 20 and so
straight after you did four heads or
four tails
imagine if after that you did head tail
head tail head tails
there's a whole heap of different
permutations you can get which at the
beginning have four heads or four tails
now that's part of how randomness works
is the fact that sure if you're dealing
with a small sample you can expect
things to be quite mixed up but that's
because there's not many permutations
head tail head tail tail head tail head
is actually you know in the same
ballpark number as big streaks but when
you're dealing with very long streaks
then you could have head head head head
head head head and then you've still got
all the permutations left to go which is
still a huge number it's not just in
that position you could get a streak of
six heads in a row or six tails in a row
at any point and and and if you do that
you end up with a whole bunch of
permutations which have a streak of six
heads or a streak of six tails I've done
this with school kids plenty of times
and what has happened in my empirical
evidence all right is that you do have
kids putting in a streak of four heads
or four tails but only once they'll only
do a maximum once so I actually crunched
the numbers and I wanted to work out if
how many how many permutations of 20
heads or tails where you had a maximum
of three heads or three tails and and
just one streak of four
it's basically what you've done plus you
also allow four heads or four tails now
only once that's basically all of this
plus one streak of four heads
or four
tails I really had to crunch the numbers
for this I'm telling you so the total
number is four hundred and seventy eight
thousand five hundred and twenty and
that corresponds to forty five point six
percent of all permutations it is bigger
but it's still less than half so this is
kind of the limit of what you're
normally mathematically literate person
thinks about randomness they actually
over over twenty flips of heads or tails
will actually cut out half of all
permutations as possibilities now half
is pretty significant when we're talking
about probability right it's like pop
you get you get rounded down all the
times I do this with a coin I will have
a street before exactly exactly more
streaks of four in a row and longer
streaks it's because I've chosen quite a
lengthy number of flips so we've done
twenty if it's 16 it doesn't work as
much the nature of randomness really
presents itself in the length of the
number of flips the way we can think
about it is how predictable is your
sequence really all you need to know is
is there a way that you can write your
sequence down of heads and tails is
there a way to do it that it's simpler
and if there is some sort of order or
pattern to it then you can actually make
it simpler but if your sequence is
actually very complicated it's actually
harder to write it any smaller than it
is and there is a way of categorizing a
random sequence by saying the easiest
way to write this sequence down is just
write it the DNA sequence which makes up
me and the fabulous person you are Brady
is actually a near random sequence
because the DNA sequence contains so
much information it actually in a way
contains lots of patterns so the way you
can think of randomness is it's
something that actually has patterns on
patterns on patterns on patents
and actually fits in very much with the
way gamblers think where they say oh I
can see a pattern here I can predict
what's going to happen next but that's
that's just randomness at work
randomness shows patterns but there's no
logic to it it's not following rules of
science or physics or anything it's the
way randomness is well know well because
you prove to me that that you weren't
gonna do it again
I think you've started you started big
this is basically you did this is like a
Hollywood script you start with a big
action sequence at the beginning and
then it becomes formulaic Thanks well
today's episode sponsor brilliant is
full of courses and quizzes and puzzles
and lots of them touch on the Gamble's
fallacy randomness probability in all
sorts of ways
and this is just a small smattering of
the great bounty of stuff you're gonna
find on the site which I'm sure you've
heard me talk about before it's amazing
for mathematics but there's also loads
of science and computer science on there
as well
lots of it's free but you can also get a
premium membership that unlocks all
sorts of other goodies I know some of
you are doing that already but here's
something you might not have thought of
buying someone else
a brilliant membership as a gift it's so
easy with just a few clicks you're
giving someone you care about hours days
maybe years of fun education
entertainment it's so had coming up with
thoughtful and original gifts for people
these days someone in your life might
really like this really clever a little
bit different go to brilliant org slash
numberphile follow the easy links to a
gift subscription and feed the brain of
someone you care about
yeah yes yeah where's my money
[Music]